yeah I'll welcome to this video um I'm
doing it let's keep it sing video and
keep it thing Nakamura I'm playing here
with white in the three-minute pula
licensee against Yakov n is pretty
strong blitz player from the US let me
check quickly the name I keep forgetting
it yeah yeah cough Nora width he's got
2,600 you see FF USCF rating so national
us rating that's about good good I am I
guess um yeah okay so I have a look at
the game we've got a pretty strange
caricom here when I camera played some
setup with g3 and it looks very much
like in advance caricom where whites
pieces are positioned in a somewhat
strange manner now nite b3 threatened
time winning winning material so yeah
look it look to a2 looks kind of funny
but maybe nights you wanna say one idea
but not see 10 you need to be careful
with bishop to be one probably so why
does a bit uncomfortable but the
position is very close to you've got
this bedrock but probably you will find
some way to get rid of the night on b3
yeah black investing some time and now
going for be 593 add this one needs to
retreat and now white probably will get
the bishop which is one feature of this
advanced calc on that white often will
be able to get the bishop am take the
the light squared Bishop for night yeah
still on if you exchange the night here
on g6 so you still have this be three
night issue you cannot play the whole
game without your look em damn h5 is
probably well I don't really think this
was a great solution so funny funny
funny funny idea but does still
interesting interesting maybe on d5
where you can sacrifice now on d5 the
fun thing of this night is hindering the
rook but the night I'll be three also
has no square I men can go to d2 but
this is weird okay white has some
attacking ideas on that age 54 maybe
maybe can sacrifice on e6 or d5 also
with the night only three like Knight to
g5 takes okay why just retreat 0h five
is also a solid kind of attacking idea
without sacrificing material immediately
and maybe there was something more
powerful okay it's a three minute game
so I cannot spend so much time okay yeah
white has a very attractive-looking
position with the night on nights on g4
and g5 but what exactly are those pieces
doing I'm
at the moment there's no threat of of a
piece sacrifice what white can try to do
is to regroup and move the g-49 and play
g4 f5 this is the only way to make any
progress here I think or maybe 93 and
then sacrifice on d5 this would be a
bishop takes d5 something like this
don't think it would work okay this one
maybe now f7 is a problem and c4 is a
problem and the rookie saying okay this
is quite quite a lot so maybe this was
was simply good for white not sure if
you want to take the rook now it looks
attractive getting the exchange but
downs not entirely clear oh so so wide
opened up the position and what is this
now 36 points against vporn so yeah what
has a pretty big guy material advantage
and he's got got better pieces Queen
Queen a7 I thought okay yeah this looks
very promising for widens it's probably
winning but the time is an issue like
I'm Eliza rather slow in this game I
thought maybe he's got some connection
issues and sister this is possible okay
this is a draw now I think perpetual but
cameras somebody to slow my assumption
is that that he's suffering yeah that he
was suffering I've got them instantly a
new game from maybe a bad connection
he's got the Italian flag p.m. so maybe
I'm there's some kind of hotel room
connection in Italy or something just
speculation maybe is out there for
tournament
on preparing their for something I don't
know but usually is much quicker of
course okay our next game I think he was
pretty pretty much winning um in the
game from position point of view okay
this game he's black now with five
minute game maybe it's better if he's
got connection issues then a little bit
more time is helpful and he's playing at
the groom faulty against the Russian
Grand Master if it does say if a very
young player this 95 is actually the the
year which was born so turning 18 this
year quite a promising player and 26
97's so very high blitz rating of course
in the as I see five minute pool where
if you play as I get get above 2600 okay
the opening was as mentioned a green
felt but it has now transposed into some
strange mixture of the goon further than
this laughs quite often you get this
kind of position from Slav but then it
the black setup is actually the same as
in this position but often White's
bishop is on c1 or d2 so not on h2 so in
Nam comparison this should be much more
promising for white than typical kind of
um sloth position we see that white has
played and only b4 b5 and made quite
some progress on the queenside world
blackest hard pressed to find any
concrete play is trying to f5 and put
some London I don't need form but um
this is some guy again losing quite some
time yeah now 95 I white so after the
you can recapture until this
some really an annoying position c6 is a
weakness centum wow yeah I'm taking on
your 5s ur not the kind of a move you
like to play yeah white um should have a
very very large advantage ship then go
okay it's a good game but I sell a
tournament game long time control game
why should win now this is some very
very huge strategic allege with the two
bishops and all those weak squares the
dark squares in blacks Kemba are
terrible your white can improve the
position without yeah something like
this will be 3 now or something like
this will be 2 doubling up possibly on
the B file yeah until one way to
continue would be to move the Queen from
a three try to use the a pond like a
queen Queen c3 at some point or you can
just get you can just exchange now if
you want to be aha now this is also good
of course entering the seventh-ranked
and yeah what exactly is black doing
here even Bishop takes d5 can be a
problematic move from black and white
then doubling on the on the 7th like
Bishop takes d5 and droop to c7 could be
a could be a good continuation probably
not the best continuation but certainly
one that that is good for white okay he
may be he troubles up on the on the bee
farm
he not sure that this was so great
getting the rook to a3 should still be
very good for white but ok now he's so
changing to this plane I suggested
before taking on d5 and I'm trying to
play on the 7th right now of course he
just text a form and this is this is a
threat just taking this and so it's
difficult to prevent i mean like and try
to drum up some some kind of counter
play but just you just take on g4 now
and take a for it yeah this is also good
problem no Queen takes h4 you can just
take d7 this is a hanging and here just
on my route c7 desrook takes you five
uh-huh yeah its invasion of whites
pieces Queen a five yeah if if
everything else fails you can take this
and take age five yeah its own it's a
huge huge advantage for white but it
feels like maybe even had some something
better before yeah that's some
international master cute thing big edge
for black hair thinking this must be a
joke comment as black is really busted
he cannot cannot move basically the only
slight issue is this look on a 3 which
is
yeah not very mobile at the moment but
it's attacking the e4 pawn black needs
to keep this born so I was needs to take
two to have a look on a 5 or somewhere
to UM to cover this and that black
simply has no move yeah he decided to do
20 km this is a funny idea try to to get
some some some past porn but why just
ignores it taking on f4 than g4 maybe
what's the idea why do some as much
ignores the center plays it as simple as
possible yeah there's really no counter
plane yeah well simply am I think a
pretty em bad position from the opening
this kind of setup should be I'm really
favorable for white some big space
advantage enter I think what did a
pretty good job of dismantling blogs
play here didn't look like him he had to
any kind of active play okay this is of
course if you need to do this then
you're in big trouble let's now our
whites pieces dominate completely dumb
black's pieces p 6 on the bishop a every
shopper on c8 coming to a six it's just
down just terrible alright so i'm not
quite sure what turn the camera is doing
maybe he's so as he left him as possible
he's certainly not very amused term
about about those two losses can be a
pretty sure about this
yeah okay yes is connected so um it's 15
min V it was just two games let's try to
find some other interesting games if
possible to maybe em get a somewhat
though longer video with more content
but it doesn't look like there's so much
going on okay you can you can know the
guy will just beat like I'm worried this
fetus AF guy is playing here with black
a king's indian against um player think
this is the netherlands right a dutch
player no name in them so don't know who
that is really and yeah it's a king's
indian where item has played without c4
but with a quick be three this is an
interesting set up this double
fianchetto and if it'll say if he
applied will see 5 and taking the d for
corn immediately okay yes he takes d4
word would have been the UM the most
common move but he decides to put some
pressure on the d4 pawn this is actually
the problem with this approach you don't
really have enough pressure on the deep
on and this now should be quite
comfortable for white simply because um
yeah exactly like this because the b-17
Bishop is a bad piece and blacks pieces
are standing on each other's toes the d7
night and the fire fanatics is I
particular problem you simply have one
one night yeah one night too much so the
same with one one night it would have
been okay but those two nights simply
don't have enough space this is why 91
was a good move f4 was a good move
I would doubt doubt them this could be
it could be premature could be yeah one
problem is if you would go on let's say
Queenie to that night xe3 this is why I
needed to play 92 our white store should
be a should be good here and we can
prepare the movie form with them Queen
to d3y our queen to YouTube something
like this and if white would would be
able to play fo and open up the file
then the e6 squared is heaven porn would
be a terribly weak yeah he tries to
prepare you five or six on dumb yeah I
think maybe it would have been better
for wide if he um would have waited a
bit with this f4 move it's not bad
strategically but not quite sure about
the timing maybe it would have been
better to prepare this better this now
I'm looks fine for black you manage to
get rid of the e porn and at the end
turn that's the question about the upon
what what is this pawn doing only three
and yeah this is so yeah Bishop a
success one idea and this and this is
also problem but maybe now we five yeah
why should try you five if possible d 5
90 x g5 mmm difficult yeah this now
should be okay again the problem is
those weak pawns and Bishop a 65 is a
weakness but this is so this is very
simple just picking up the exchange and
if you will lose one exchange then
probably you also lose control of the
e-file
with the rook on g7 already know yeah
maybe just queen somewhere a six or
queen a tree check or queen whatever d7
Andrew creator oh yeah yeah got the big
choice yeah Luke takes the foreign
resins g5 who can just take care for if
you want on or take you 1 and cover the
night yeah now Queen somewhere f7 yo
yeah I think the black player he really
played a bad opening with white didn't
really punish it yeah this is just an
extra look on extra exchange of white
eggs but the position completely falls
apart here here p.m. maybe f4 so it's a
bit premature maybe prepare this in the
game of the f1 Knight to g4 and f6 this
these two nights somehow coordinate it
but maybe you should play move like a
ch3 or Queenie to first and then prepare
all this and then it's really
questionable does this black position
with the weird bishop on b7 and those
weaknesses so um this was maybe a chance
to to get some some good advantage in
the in the opening and I can we're
actually locked on again but probably
not sure if you will play or maybe he
did just change something in his some
connection setup this is possible he
really was a quite slow for his standard
yeah I keep checking from any game song
on him I have another game by this guy
and he's playing some play from the US
side I don't know this guy intuitive and
don't oh we've got Nakamura again
actually it also not not bad at all ok
so I'm a French defense will be three
against big al there's no name in there
but big Alice some players on foreign
ICC for for ages ok so I'm sort of Kings
Indian attack with somewhat weird wide
set up with them b3 yeah very close
position with all bishops here Finch
head out now why term prepares the moves
on F form
yeah big tension now I'm in the center
thoes en def pawns I'm standing in front
of each other so they're among multiple
captures possible quite often it is a
good idea to to keep the tension as the
site who actually moves first it's um
Anna disadvantage okay this is a very
general observation so it doesn't apply
so often of course not all the time Adam
it's it's quite common that you
shouldn't release the tension in this
case however we see that Nakamura maybe
has the ideas like it tonight f5 and 92
III maybe not immediately but in general
using the III square okay and why term
here goes with the place with B form I'm
sacrificing a corn I'm not quite sure
what the compensation for this is
supposed to be maybe he am yes the idea
to play b5 and then get back the d4 pawn
then Bishop 32 now with the idea of b5
this could be am quite okay for what and
now be five exchange on b7 and take d
phone maybe this is some about them a
level endgame you know I don't think
that um White has nem any problems I can
just take and King King up yeah now 92
yeah defo was really a bad wolf Nyjah to
will just blundered the sea for porn if
Y place King f4 can you three or
something then he is probably somewhat
better even and this so this just cost
them a couple of porns maybe you still
have drawn chances you can now play King
to c6 and now neither be formally
covering d5 and then taking on CSM I
cannot really calculate this to the end
but down some chances for white to hold
yeah what is black doing now difficult
yeah nochum own 10 why that I don't
really understand did he choose I know
what yeah sometimes I nakamura saw
actions are really hard to comprehend
for some reason he just resigned this
game which is of course weird it's it
was impossible to lose maybe it was a
draw it is possible but it wasn't it
wasn't in any way M dangerous form for
him yeah well this son looks like the
terrible position for black white has
got a huge advantage in space here on
the king's island is a near near opening
off the edge file already with the big
attack to come you can Castle quickly on
the long side just F for now maybe yeah
this is a funny position like has some
no space at all yeah he gets the five
square now for the night with just some
some compensation for the for the lack
of space but what what is the night on e
8 doing ever in this game it's got no
square you can go to c7 at some point
but White has such a huge space space
advantage he just needs to play actually
94 f 3 okay
an ID to to f3 just exchange this so
this night okay place it in a more
technical fashion this position where
you need to get if you get rid of this
this night this is also this is also
neat we take SOG D to G seven and eight
seven is checkmate so black loses loses
the house this was nice if this was too
quick just step a few seconds i'm back
in the in the video and look at the
final position he resided bit quickly it
was really lost but you didn't see
really what was going on just go back a
couple of seconds and tevin have a
longer look okay I'm Sicilian here with
Bishop b5 the Russell emo um one of the
lines were wider takes on c6 I always
had a hard time to understand these
positions I mean for both sides I always
said problems to to figure out what was
going on yes he three looks like a very
weird move I mean okay I understand I
stand before him but what about g5 now
maybe what does sound what is why doing
after d5 now this also looks good need
to probably play see for now okay well I
don't think he minds taking taking the
exchange here or this one this is even
stronger damaging white structure taking
on f3 and this is this is just lost f5
was winning instead of this f5 Queen g5
I mean this is also winning f5s probably
it's just deadly but he could have
played a 5-1 move earlier I think he
will do now no white resigned and now
just f5 and and its mate yeah this was
quite a quite a bad game for narcotic
porn in here
so on was this some weird some weirdo
d4c 5d take seafoam interesting yet
looks a bit like and black is just a
pawn down down maybe I'm yeah white can
can take on v6 Bishop takes before check
you just step to F 2 and then white is a
porn up maybe 25 was an idea i'm not
sure yeah night c4 to g6 maybe about 10
d5 your nights before you can play d5
yeah very unclear position really those
two points are looking look very m very
dangerous but White's king is some
problem and you you don't really have a
good development area he's opening up
the position 95 coming yeah I think I
think I'm black has some substantial
advantage now 95 yes still 95 just
intending to take a three and what is
white is we're doing
yeah threatening mate but what if you
take it three anyway it is no major not
threatening mate Nige xe3 queen age
seven king of eight yeah the brutal
bluff worked it was just a bluff II
could you could take you three but all
this this also looks looks weird Queen a
7 mm not to have five yeah white skin
position looks looks really really
terrible that sometimes so it's just
dodging bullets and at the enter there
is no mate night f5 maybe your queen is
having something like this yeah white
probably has g3 let's say Queen um III
check just 33 guy I don't see when it
looks it looks very very dangerous for
white but Queen III or something yeah
white is opponent and if he is not mated
then he's probably just fine
well I can just take this rook and he
didn't take the rook this was lucky the
bishop takes a three was just possible
maybe naka wanted to wanted to play a
rogue a 2 i'm not sure yeah black and
doesn't have a bad position I mean yeah
yeah the exchange yo your porn down but
it's it's not not a big issue our pieces
are fine black side and white skin
position is still a bit insecure it's
not like why this getting mated quickly
but you you don't have a really secure
position for the king of you go King to
g2 then you're in the long diagonal now
ha g58 tries to open up maybe this was
so what's a really good move take it for
now I maybe well maybe just take it for
your blacks position is some not the
problem but the clock time it's got 12
for 12 seconds and going down
ya Wan maybe white can play something
like this about rook takes g5 now this
looks very strong Queen to d8 as
possible queen age six yeah but black
lost some time done yeah black hood good
could win more than once but it's three
minute chess and if the opponent is
playing so quickly it's difficult I mean
I played naw Kham also a number of times
and I had my share of winning positions
but actually winning them in this time
the sum is really difficult ok so
entertaining games and what is going on
I don't mind to do one arm two more
games but i'm not sure that the play ok
I just recognize that this also um
Grandmaster Sarah one playing is some
playing a three minute game against them
Joan international masks and we are
already near the end of of the game
plots down some magnums Oh complex
position were wide just grab this efore
porn I think you will take you for now
and why this pawn up Queen takes the
fauna and maybe black and takes c3 aha
ok yeah it looks that looks somewhat
better for white I think with the the
good Bishop only form but the black has
some so very decent pieces
like it's not them not in a passive
opposite okay now here he just gave away
peace and now it's checkmate what a
finish very weird finish light suddenly
getting checkmated here what happened
King edge 8 he took and then yeah just
queen takes I mean okay and you you
return the piece on on age 7 but this
was too simple okay so one more game
here by yeah so he's not not blundering
into mates often relief okay we had a
calc on here with them and pan off black
playing against the isolated pawn and
then here here actually a black n plano
texas ruby text with c3 and night XD
forward he decided on something else now
attacking the deform on let's see
castles yeah black sometimes can take
before but it's a it's a quite risky
business okay now like can ever take
that you should take the h7 at the end
as a problem
yeah what has the typical kind of from
flu and peace play for the isolated
Queens pawn and like must try to make
use of structural advantages like the
isolated phone on the hanging pawns
which can be a weakness but frankly
speaking I'm not quite sure if black
will manage to get any meaningful play
against those pawns what is it's quite
quick here here also black I mean has
played age 6 which can be a big problem
yeah exactly and now Queen to h3 Bishop
takes h6 coming all this move is also
interesting Bishop takes h6 threatening
here every tweenage for but ok then but
should be seven but white white could
even no reply f3 it's a no big deal at
all yeah night edge products Queen to h4
it looks really strong threatening
Bishop takes h6 we should be 7f three
what is black doing then Bishop takes h6
is such a strong thread I don't really
see a move maybe you need to return to
2g8 with a night or something all right
okay this is also interesting of course
yeah if the black black must take
everything else is so passive and now
Queen Queen somewhere be too you cannot
play Queen d6 because of 90 xf7 and it
probably needs to go we have into whites
camp into the lion's mouth grabbing all
kinds of material this is a
not not unusual for for yesyes likes to
grab all kinds of material and try to
get away with it ok white has sacrificed
a piece and now at XD f 69 and ta a drug
so on the double check weird one not
sure what right is doing I think he
needs to attend to the kingside you
cannot move the rock for example or play
Bishop a 6 because Knight takes Queen
takes f6 wins wins h6 and also probably
will need to check bully to a check made
so black probably loses the rukon in the
corner yeah something like this and now
Queen takes eight but this means why
does an exchange up and then still has
an attack yeah white simply m maintains
his very active position now threatening
not g6 untung got quite an obvious
threat but yeah I will I was just about
to suggest this need to use the rook on
the third-ranked gap black still um has
some most weaknesses covered so it
doesn't look like a very quick mate but
you can improve the position it will
yeah this looks good for what getting
rid of the dangerous pawn the a pawn so
Sam quite you may be the only slide hope
for for counter play and like us down to
now six five four seconds it probably
lose on time this looked like a pretty
good game by white i would i would say
he really did did a good job out playing
ceremonia now he's just playing nonsense
move but waiting on time Black now has a
look up or something but he knew you
would want to be known time sometimes
you don't really pay so much attention
if you if you know that you went on time
then you are you sometimes play a
careless movement and spoil the actual
position knowing that you you will win
for sure by the clock yeah like um where
is not playing I would wouldn't mind of
course to have a look at the one more of
his games but he's not playing we have
grandma's Dre f also on but he's usually
playing one minute yeah he's playing one
minute so this is difficult to to keep
it slip to UM to put it mildly yeah
there's no game going on by the
Grandmaster some and three or five
minutes yes alright this video is some
okay last game one game better for now
final game has started I was about to
wrap up this video but let's do this
this video yeah the G takes f6 variation
the Bronstein Larson line I did I
produce a video on this in German
language for eyes I see if you
understand some german then i can
recommend this video to you it's
accessible via the icc webpage chess
club calm and then on click on videos
and
select German as the language then you
get some videos in German language by me
on on openings there are three videos
already on and that's more to come
alright so um this is already a very
good position for black white has some
quite some yeah some strange setup but
ok it is still solid by white it's very
unofficial but solid yeah this was 96
was a good move an interesting move
allowing this change of the pawn
structure and white actually went went
for this took on b5 would just think as
a positional error and pretty really am
serious one actually here white has got
problems with his horns they're all on
dark squares and whites bishop is also a
dark squared bishop won't see one while
blacks bishop on f8 it's not hindered by
by his pawns he can play just for
example a 6 + f5 and then you've got all
all um pawns on light squares and your
bishop is the good one not necessarily
you want to play those moves I'm just
mentioning it especially f5 I would be
would be cautious with us f5 also we can
see 5 square but black n can easily
improve the position rook c8 rooks e6
and so on and try to improve this was
good white am prepared to to exchange
the bed bishop distance of course
helpful but this set up with the b5 also
allowed this night to get to a good
square on d5 and now it is replaced by
the king who's got a good square on d5
but the worst is over for white with his
bishop exchange if this was something
that black couldn't prevent exchanging
this Bishop once you want then then I am
overestimated blacks chances I thought
that black was already am much better
but this
he wasn't so one so awful and now my to
play d 5 which is a strong move if black
now takes on d5 then white can play
against the d5 pawn with rook to e1 and
what's what's black supposed to do brook
c5 is answered by be4 and you just lose
and after ETA xt5 also f5 is gone so
very am very annoying position yeah
maybe rookie one was better instead of
Rube d1 also here rook d to e 1 could be
good getting widen to himself pin yeah
maybe we'll create or cd8 yeah well I'd
still um BM be Frankie and predict a
black win this is just a slightly better
for white but 01 probably is by far the
better and game player is really a great
end game player so um let's see what
happens now the rukon d6 that just
covers this weakness ma'am okay if Y
just stays now rook e 2 2 f2 and all the
way back then it's difficult would like
to do anything but it is just equal now
I think it looks like a white has got
some activity but this is really not
much hmm this could be could be a
problem from like it's got the worst
pawn structure but he's got always this
v6 as a reserve ins can you see
should be a draw and now just kick back
and it's a draw difficult to see em
someone losing this now we have position
2 times gap King III draw not much that
you can do o king before but I still
draw it's still a draw Oh something's
happening I'm not sure that this was
such a great idea for white I mean I
mean why Dwight didn't make any progress
okay we have some some action it's
probably still a draw they both get the
Queen yeah yeah yeahs such time as the
problem set down to a couple of seconds
and really not not really not very fast
yeah probably he lives on time could
have taken the queen but yeah the
typical nonsense at the end right white
even blundering the Queen a couple of
times but the time is the problem yeah
um it's a shame that that's not more of
three minutes and two seconds
incremental just avoiding those some
kind of stranger and to game yeah thanks
for watching hope you enjoyed this cute
thing of Nakamura fiddle CF and at the
end here on grandma's heroin thanks for
watching I'll be back soon